good afternoon I too wish to begin by
thanking Prime Minister Modi for this
timely call for a regional initiative to
combat the increasing threat of co19 in
this arc region in times of crisis we do
come together in 2003 for example when
the region face the threat of SARS
the Modi's took the initiative and
hosted an extraordinary meeting of Sauk
health ministers it adopted a regional
common strategy for tech Linda why is no
country on its own can succeed in
combating the virus it requires a shared
response and proceed in scale the first
code 19 case was confirmed in the
Maldives
on 7 March to date there are 13
confirmed cases fortunately no deaths so
far since January this year the Maldives
has been taking steps to get ready for a
possible outbreak we set in place
standard operational procedures and
facilities for treatment and quarantine
in various islands in the event of major
outbreak in the country our health
facilities will have to cope with care
needed for both of residents in the
thousands of tourists who visit the
Maldives every year our priority now is
to use precautionary measures to contain
the virus as much as possible so it's
not a burden our limited resources the
unique geography of the Maldives
always present itself both as an
opportunity is always a challenge the
dispersed islands make it easier for us
to isolate communities whenever there is
an suspected case but in the event that
a person tests positive in the outer
islands and is seriously ill requiring
specialist care the person has to be
transported to the capital male this is
extremely costly and puts enormous
pressure on an overstretch team of
healthcare workers or tertiary hospitals
in the region's are currently under
development shortage of healthcare
professionals in general and shortage of
specialist doctors in particular are
always major challenges and in a crisis
such as this these challenges are
several times greater the Maldives is
fortunate to have received general
assistance from India and I convey my
government's appreciations to Prime
Minister Modi and the people of India we
have received medicine and a visiting
medical relief team to work with
Maldivian healthcare professionals
excellencies in the Maldives the widest
is showing in the most destructive
measure the country's vulnerabilities to
external shocks tourist arrivals started
to decline considerably through leaks
before the first case was reported in
February this year arrivals declined by
14.3% and in the first 10 days of this
month and I will say already declined by
22 to
8% the decline in tourist arrivals has
now become so sharp that if the current
trend continues we will have a 35%
growth this year any significant decline
in tourist arrivals as a ripple effect
on the Maldives economy tourism
contributes over quarter of the
country's GDP and is the source of well
over 2/3 of foreign currency to the
country every other job creating and
revenue generating activity in the
country is either directly or indirectly
dependent on the tourism industry our
industry is also deeply linked to many
businesses and supply chains with his
hock region who will feel who will feel
the knock-on effects from the downtown
don't turn in the mall dears China and
Italy are the most severely affected
countries of the virus and they are also
the number 1 and number 3 source markets
for Maldives tourists since the
beginning of February in the case of
China and March in the case of Italy
arrivals from these two countries have
been restricted as a result of this
decline the Maldives is now facing a
serious shortfall in foreign currency
earning estimated to be at US dollar 450
million in the foreign currency short
for continuous it will have a
detrimental impact on the mall this
economy which has an extremely high
dependency on imports the revenue in
foreign currency short for are also
seriously hamper in the government's
ability to respond to co 819 rapidly
the decline means serious shortage in
total government revenue current
estimates show that if tourist arrivals
continue to decline
maldis will be looking at a shortfall in
government revenues between us to 135 to
130 5.9 million and us to the four
hundred forty six point six million this
year I am therefore in full agreement
with Prime Minister Modi on the need to
formulate a comprehensive regional
strategy such as strategy should we
believe compromise three key elements
first we should create pace for closer
cooperation between the health emergency
agencies to ensure that the countries in
sauk have unhindered exchanges of
information about the virus and best
practices second there's a profound need
to formulate an economic reserve the
cage targeted to the affected countries
a comprehensive regional strategy to
fight co 819 should include a long term
recovery plan for the region I will be
happy to speak further on these elements
in the discussions Thank You Prime
Minister Modi Thank you Thank You
excellency
now I request his Excellency President
Raj moksha to share his thoughts leaving
expenses first understand honorable
Prime Minister of India
Shri Narendra Modi for initiating this
video conference to share our
experiences of ideas and best practices
and also to understand the challenges we
face
and further discuss what measures to be
taken to combat this deadly coronavirus
our biggest challenge is to stop or me
mind the virus entering into Sri Lanka
and control the spreading of the virus
with Sri Lanka for this purpose we have
been tourists and other people they
drink Sri Lanka specially from new
countries and also South Korea Iran
following the with Indus following the
guidelines and statistics relating to
the spread of the virus issued by the
World Health Program organization we
have also second status because we have
a large number of Sri Lankans working
especially in Italy and South Korea we
cannot stop our Sri Lankans coming back
to the home country they have therefore
taken all to subject those returning to
Sri Lanka to a food in the current
period in selected quarantine centers as
it is important to restrict social
gatherings we have advanced the usual
April school holidays to commit from
11th March further we have closed all
the universities another education
in studios also the name of minimizing
social interaction our first case was
reported in Sri Lanka was a Chinese lady
tourist who since has been cured and
already left
Sri Lanka the first Sri Lanka to be
infected was a - a guy who had
contracted the virus from a few Italian
tourists well already left the country
at present we have 11 cases being
treated in the hospital there were no
deaths reported so far we have a
specialized infectious diseases I get
close to the see Colombo with intensive
care facilities this hospital has
successfully treated even the first case
reported in all other Hospital they
submitted to treat any suspected cases
or corona virus cases proposed proper
personal protective equipment is used we
have also requested those who are to
show flu similar to seek urgent medical
attention and also self quarantine
themselves close associate of this
person showing any flute interns have
also been strongly advised to be subject
to self quarantine currently the area
please and the public health inspectors
are closely monitoring the progress of
the suspected
patience public health inspectors
undertake daily research to check on
these percent for self quarantine we
have also established a national task
force comprising all major stakeholders
with the power and authority today
crucial decisions I mean set up and
build on daily basis with close and
constant monitoring of all aspects
relating to the spread of this deadly
virus 24/7 office with what Lyons has
been established to coordinate all
acting related to battling the spread of
the virus currently and testing and
treatment of suspected and confirmed
cases Dharma to Sri Lanka has taken some
additional steps to effectively meet
this unfortunate disaster the Department
of Health started giving out health
warning and advice on precautionary
measures needed to be followed for
prevention of the spread of the virus
this is done through mass media
presidential media division press
briefings press bullet et cetera
general public were educated not to go
for pen buying or face masks and
services etc this was quite effective 12
hospitals were declared as suitable for
caring of possible
- affected cases across the country
managing of stocks of personal
protective equipment such as mass glove
scientist and other medical items
required for treatment of patients also
started since the high-risk area for the
corona virus was the city of Mohan
Mumbai Province in China there was a
requirement to evacuate 34 sri lankan
students and their families back to Sri
Lanka this was done by the National
Carol Street entire lines which flew
from Colombo to Han and back to Colombo
with all 34 passengers this is 34
students on arrival were immediately
quarantined by the Sri Lankan they are
forced before they were taken to a
military facility in the central hills
for quarantine for 14 days under the
supervision of the army medical team
none of them contracted the virus and
all sent home on completion of the 14
days current I'd billion at the same
time another 750 Sri Lankans were
studying in various universities in
different provinces of China and the
government facilities they were returned
back to Sri Lanka
these students were instructed to be
self
currenty for 14 days under the
supervision and monitored by a local
health authorities as you know probably
that our parliament has been
on 2nd March and the general elections
will be held on its 25th April
so the nominations are being accepted
from 12 March up to 19 but therefore we
have to take precautions to discourage
large meetings like gatherings but the
elections will be held as planned when
the World Health Organization WH to
declare Kovach 19 handling an indicator
that fundamental public health
interventions can still limit the spread
of the virus and drive down cases even
where it was transmitting widely advisor
his virtue for travelers and
precautionary measures were taken by
limiting travel overseas of Sri Lankans
address it is essential to do so almost
all the major sporting events
international conferences meeting large
gatherings have been postponed or
canceled all schools universities and
other educational establishments
including free schools throughout the
country has been closed from particular
periods ranging from 2 weeks to 16 even
gatherings for religious purpose shall
be stopped by respective religious
leaders initially from two we'd also
insurance of on arrival visas has been
suspected for all countries
travel advisories said to the Alliance
not to uplift passengers from several
countries mostly from EU countries
travel advisories also said that any
passenger coming from countries that we
have defined will be quarantined for 40
days in Sri Lanka stand sizing of public
transport also prevents from today's
back so as because of these reasons of
economy has taken a similar blue due to
the coronavirus particularly in tourism
most of other tourists are from Italy
Germany and other new countries and now
there is a ban on the running our
tourist industry was just recovering
after last year's April 25 there in
Japan our exports are also adversely
affected therefore I strongly recommend
the South leaders to formulate a
mechanism to assist our economies to
fight over this very difficult period
I also wish to recommend that the Sun
ministerial-level room be established to
discuss share these practices and
coordinate regional matters on combating
corona white thank you thank you
excellent thank you Thank You excellency
I now call upon her Excellency Prime
Minister say
Haseena to share her thoughts thank you
very much good afternoon to all the sort
leaders first of all as hands Prime
Minister Modi for taking this initiative
I also thanks for bringing and hosting
23 of our students from Mohan along with
Indian students during the quantile
period who need to devise a strong surf
wild strategy to fight this public
health rail and to protect our citizens
we successfully prevented entry of the
virus through strong surveillance and
rigorous checkup at all international
airports the force and land poles as of
now we had only three covered 19
imported cases they have already
recovered there are two new imported
cases from Europe who have no local or
community transmission of any Kovac 19
case we have set up a national committee
to provide guidance to concern people
from all ministries at all levels we
have also undertaken mass in our knees
raising campaigns everywhere in
Bangladesh through all available medias
including social media my party workers
at all levels are active in awareness
raising local body representatives are
vigilant to enforce home on time if
necessary we have kept for newly built
hospital including the quit material
spittle in Dhaka dedicated to
exclusively deal with common finding
patients in addition there is no there's
one more hospital in Russia to
exclusively handle commit and in
patients who have also your mod separate
ways
in every hospital in all the day or in
all districts to treat carbonated
patients a few vacant buildings have
been identified where makeshift
hospitals can be established in case
there is any such need we also have
trained health workers at Koopa till
11:00
schoolchildren are also being trained to
follow necessary personal hygiene
we have stockpiles of testing kits
infrared thermometers isolation gowns
and math excellency I have some
proposals that all sort countries need
to cooperate and collaborate closely to
fight this pandemic we need to force
collaboration through our collective
capacity expertise and resources we are
ready to share our capacity and
expertise as well as the best practice
with desert countries including
providing logistics support if required
to continue this dialogue at technical
level
our health ministers health theater is a
relevant health experts can also have
this kind of video conferences to
discuss specific areas of cooperation
WTO Southeast Asia regional factor may
be invited to these video conferences we
believe it is extremely important to
establish an institution to prevent and
fight against any public health threats
in South Asia region in future in our
search charter it is already there about
the health
so we can work together for future and
in future any problem arise we can work
together and we can exchange or share
our experience and Bangladesh will be
happy to host us institution if you
kindly all if you all kindly agree soon
see I really thank you very much
especially Prime Minister Modi to take
the initiative and also I appreciate
that after a long time all the thought
leaders get together so it's a very
crucial time for all of us so we have to
think about our people peoples you know
goodwill so I hope that this will show
an new dimension our path to help our
people peoples of all our country and
all the region thank you very much thank
you
Thank You excellency I now request his
Excellency Prime Minister wholly to make
his mouth
right honorable Prime Minister Narendra
Modi ji distinguished guests of the
state and government of Sark member days
namaste and good afternoon
first of all I would like to thank Prime
Minister Narendra Modi ji for taking
this important and timely decision which
I want develop our collective wisdom and
efforts will help us devices sound
robust to strategy for the SARC region
here we fight the queried 19 panda I
wish to tempra mr. Balaji and all the
distinguished leaders of South memory
states her kind words and best wishes on
by a speedy recovery even though we had
detected one suspected important case
important case but the province 19 test
fruit- yet we are aware of the high risk
of possible outbreak at any time
we remain alert from preventing it
we have taken several measures to
enhance our preparedness our efforts at
the moment are geared towards preventing
this disease to enter into our country
our national foods
I am personally overseeing and guiding
the government efforts multi-agency
coordination committees have been set up
at the center provinces and local levels
to mobilize governmental force in the
synergetic manner we have restricted
international moments we shall arrival
facility for all foreigners and
non-resident definition with foreign
password has been suspended movement of
this country moment of third country
nationals via vendors has been suspected
shortest PRC health certificate is been
mandatory to obtain visa from Nepali
mrs. Abel for essential travels to Nepal
we have suspended a sense of work permit
for demand intentional spar overseas
employment international passengers are
required to go through the screening
process other health risks and the
international them there are provisions
for self quarantine
for certain categories of travelers we
are strengthening quarantine as
in all provinces hospitals and Harrods -
Alison Mars and intensive parts per
treatment we have we are enhancing
capacity of hospitals health workers are
being provided with personal protects
protective equipment and necessary
incentives to motivate them all the
permits per mountaineering expedition
for a spring 2020 have been suspended
and all major international conferences
have been pushed
okay thank you very much - thank you
Thank You excellency now I call upon his
Excellency Prime Minister dr. Lotte
shearing who is an experienced surgeon
prime star sharing we are all keen to
hear you please thank you thank you your
excellency before I start I would like
to take this opportunity to convey my
King's greetings to all the heads of the
states and hepl heads of the governments
here as we speak my king is out of the
capital he is in the district places
ensuring health care services ensuring
Corbett 19 surveillance system and
trying to motivate our health care
services and service providers as well
as asking all the people of Bhutan to be
on the same page when this pandemic
strikes baton so with this I I also
would like to take this opportunity to
express my King's greetings and
greetings of all of us to Prime Minister
only for his speedy recovery and
similarly we also would like to wish
Prime Minister Hasina for our fathers
our hundredth birthday celebration in
few days so with this I would like to
thank Prime Minister Modi for your
excellent leadership to bring all of us
together because togetherness is
required at all times but when the whole
world is fighting one common disease
that we cannot see with our naked eyes I
think is very important that all of us
come together and leave behind our
differences and number two I think it is
very important that we communicate very
clearly on this communicate between all
the leaders of the world communicate
between central government with local
government communicate with the health
planners and the people of the nations
so I think this is very timely and I
would like to thank Prime Minister Modi
ji for your excellent leadership on this
to tell my colleagues on
on the experience of Bhutan on the loan
COBIT 19 positive that we had it was the
5th of this month last 5th of March
evening we had one zone imported case a
boot on lava a Bhutan visitor we wanted
to visit Bhutan came to Bhutan and then
on the third day of his visit he showed
some very abnormal sign symptoms and
then on suspicion we we found out that
he was kovat 19 the positive by evening
yet we wanted to confirm it and the
conformity test came just before
midnight around 11:30 p.m. by then our
health officials had all gathered in the
ministry even my King also came to the
ministry and we all started because we
knew that we had the first confirmed
positive case so throughout the night we
work very hard our salvation system that
was already in place was initiated
activated overnight and starting
midnight till 7:00 a.m. the coming
morning that is 6th of March we had we
managed to trace the whole path of the
first positive case we managed to
identify all the 48 primary contacts we
managed to send all the contactors in
surveillance team to their respective
places and inform them of the importance
of house quarantine that first morning
and then as the day unfolded we managed
to pull them out and bring them to the
formally identified quarantine
facilities so over 78 hours we managed
to identify all 48 primary contacts from
three different parts of the country
wherever artorias had visited and we
also managed to manage to initiate the
medical team that we had identified to
treat in case if you had a positive case
and then she was isolated and treatment
started and it all happened because our
health ministry under minister
Duchenne's leadership everything was
planned beforehand and then the king was
also our team was also awake the whole
night trying to coordinate the whole
thing and bring all the primary contacts
together
we do not wish to have positive cases in
any countries but to have a positive
case in this manner and to be able to
identify all the primary contacts and
isolate them I thought was the huge
success that we brought in then starting
from there we managed to treat him take
care of him very very well and his
family wanted the patient back home so
he was successfully air evacuated day
before yesterday and he reach his
hometown last night actually so we wish
him a speedy recovery all the people of
Bhutan send our sincere prayers for his
speedy recovery but the fact is since as
we all know and as all the heads of the
country I shared here this is this is
uphill tasks because we really don't see
our enemy this a pandemic that is
challenging all of us do not follow
geographical boundaries that's why as I
said we it's very important for all of
us to be on the same page and as we all
know that it affects the elderly people
and it affects more people with comorbid
conditions so similarly the aftermath of
this disease will also affect the
smaller and vulnerable economies more
hardly than the better ones so we are
equally concerned that as we fight and
as we try to contain this disease we are
also concerned about economic outcomes
of this disease so therefore I would
like to support all the proposals that
were made before me and also to be very
very sure that we all will share our
limited resources that we have share the
technologies that we have and also to
have frequent such meetings so that with
the changes in time and with the changes
of the demands of this pandemic we also
come and regroup ourselves and also
would like to propose that we must have
a similar cooperation in economic up get
up on this issue because all the smaller
economies are disproportionately hit so
with this I'm sure my other colleagues
will have a lot of points to share and I
also wish I would like to contribute as
the
discussion goes on so as of now I would
like to thank all the heads of the
states and help other countries and
governments as well as Prime Minister
Modi for your initiative thank you very
much thank you
Thank You excellency now I call upon his
Excellency dr. Jafar Madea who also had
medical experience to share his thoughts
and assalamu alaikom two honorable heads
of state and government and
secretary-general shock first of all i
would like to wish good health
to his Excellency Prime Minister of
Nepal your excellencies the covert 19
pandemic is one of the most serious
global health emergencies witnessed in
the last hundred years at the same time
when it has been characterized as a
global pandemic it is deemed
controllable as well provided timely and
appropriate public health my ears are
put in place with over 100 55,000
infections 500 8 8 5833 deaths and 138
countries involved no nation and no
region on earth can afford to be
unresponsive
least of all Sark which is home to
one-fifth of the humanity several of the
word's largest mega cities and many of
the most densely populated regions
Pakistan shares the common concern over
the potential of covert 19 affecting
South Asia all our countries now have
confirmed cases mercifully the Sauk
region has so far evaded the worst
ravages but given the experience of
other countries in other continents
there is absolutely no room for any
competition see while hoping for the
best we have to prepare for the worst
the World Health Organization's four
pronged
advice offers
reasonable way forward namely a prevent
B detect C respond and also the conduct
research and innovation along the way
excellencies Pakistan has been involved
in containment efforts right from the
outset of the outbreak
we have been alert to the dangers and
have put in place appropriate public
health by years and developed required
protocols and guidelines for the safety
of our people we have been matching our
mayor's to real-time risk assessments
while we have stressed the need for
prevention and caution we have strongly
advised against panic a calm calculated
and deliberate response is the need of
the Ark Pakistan was among the first few
countries to undertake a joint external
evaluation for the state of preparedness
to cope with health emergencies in the
context of international health
regulations 2005 in close collaboration
with World Health Organization we have
been taking steps to appropriately
restrict movement to and from the
affected countries regulate for flights
institute health screening mayor's at
entry points by member states and
establish quarantine / isolation
facilities diagnosed cases are being
isolated and contacts are be increased
proactively Prime Minister Imran Khan is
personally overseeing these efforts
presented resultantly Pakistan has
managed so far to keep the cases to a
relative minimum an achievement that
whu-oh has recently recognized as a good
practice and has commanded it National
Security Committee recently convened for
the first time on a national health
issue chaired by the prime minister
Imran Khan and has decided to take major
steps to contain the spread of covert 19
the four pillars of our response
strategy include one governance and
financing to prevention three mitigation
and D for communication we have decided
decided internal here one to close all
our educational institutions for three
weeks closed the entire Western model
for two weeks restrict international
flights two to three airports only and
to burn all large public gatherings and
reinforce screening and administrative
mayor's at the seaports and at the
ground crossings the situation is being
monitored closely and appropriate my
ears are being taken through a
systematic consultative review process
the National Disaster Management
Authority has been mandated to lead the
interagency effort and command and
control centers have been established at
the federal and provincial levels
effective coordination and surveillance
at all levels is critically important
excellencies the covent 19 pandemic
forces us to think not in terms of
nations and states but as he collected
if our health systems disease
surveillance systems and prevented my
ears are unable to cope the human and
economic cost alone can be staggering
the cumulative impact will dampen
region-wide growth prospects and
negatively affect the national
development agendas at their turn stages
of development the Sauk members can ill
afford such a setback the unprecedented
challenge therefore warrants an
unprecedented response we must recognize
that the national and local responses
still remain that the key and and they
are most critical it is equally
important to pursue however
evidence and science-based responses
stigmatization and stereotyping is
counterproductive the SARC secretariat
is best placed to coordinate regional
endeavours but this in view Pakistan
proposes like other excellencies that
the SoCs Secretariat be mandated to one
establish a working group of respective
national authorities for health
information and data exchange as well as
coordination for responses in real time
and to like his Excellency President of
Maldives and Her Excellency Prime
Minister of Bangladesh Pakistan would
like to reiterate its earlier proposal
of hosting South health ministers
conference at an appropriate time three
reach out on behalf of South countries
to specialize development partners
including World Health Organization for
mobilization for technical advice and
resources for followed whu-oh guidelines
and implement exit health screening for
travellers in the region to avoid
cross-border spread by a regional
mechanism is proposed to share disease
surveillance data in real-time about
prevalence and incidence of communicable
diseases and public health events of
regional significance and lastly learn
from the learn from and disseminate the
experience of sock observer States
particularly China which has effectively
addressed the covered 19 challenge
despite being from where it originated
excellencies the challenge at hand
demands sagacity billion and synergy of
action the strength and resilience of
the people of South Asia is well known
we have no doubt that we will
overcome these challenges thank you your
excellencies Thank you Thank You
excellency
thank you all for sharing your thoughts
on the situation and the steps you have
taken we all agree that we are facing a
serious challenge
we do not know and ag8 know what shape
the pandemic pandemic will take in the
coming days it is clear that we have to
work together we can respond best by
coming together not growing apart
collaboration not confusion preparation
not panicked in this spirit of
collaboration let me share a few ideas
on what India can offer to this joint
effort I propose we create a kovat 19
emergency fund this could be based on
voluntary contributions from all of us
India can start with an initial offer of
10 billion u.s. dollars for this fund
any of us can use the fund to meet the
cost of immediate actions our foreign
secretaries through our embassies
can coordinate quickly to finalize the
utilization of this fund we are
assembling a rapid response team of
doctors and specialists in India along
with testing kits and other equipment
they will be on standby to be placed at
your disposal if required we can also
quickly arrange online training capsules
for your emergency response teams this
will be based on the model we have used
in our own country to raise the capacity
of all our emergency staff we had set up
an integrated disease surveillance
portal to better trace possible virus
carriers and the people they contacted
we could share this this is surveillance
software with Sark partners and training
on using this let us also use existing
facilities like the Sark Disaster
Management Center to pull in the best
practices among all of us looking ahead
we could create a common research
platform to coordinate research on
controlling epidemic disease within our
South Asian region the Indian Council of
medical results can offer help
coordinate a coordinating such an
exercise
we can also ask our experts to
brainstorm on the longer-term economic
consequences of Kovach 19 and how we can
insulate our internal trade and our
local value chains from its impact
finally this is not the first nor the
last such pandemic that will affect us
we can also ask our experts to
brainstorm on the longer-term economic
consequences of kovat 19 and how we can
insulate our internal trade and our
local chains from its impact this can
help to prevent such infections from
spreading across our region
and allows us to keep our internal
moments free I call upon his Excellency
President Ghani to share his thoughts
measure the number of cases of a solid
60 no deaths and as of yet their five
provinces but the case I make is the
following our refugees from Iran are
being sent back in droves I would like
to make the case that dealing with this
flaw in the Arab profit three provinces
particularly here in rosenthal is a
regional challenge because
thousands of people are coming from an
infected area in the period in which the
incubation takes place as the detection
rate takes place who would like to offer
particularly they're not province where
we are making major efforts as a model
in terms of organization our National
Security Council has chaired a number of
times and we've created a task force
under the vice-president and all the
provinces we are reorganizing our budget
etc but let me welcome your initiative
we would like to be delighted to
contribute to this voluntary fun but the
face is mr. Prime Minister we would
suggest we need to think about the next
six months as one king where the
pandemic is likely to unfold thank god
weather is going for warming and it
showed that the negative consequences
but the vaccine is not likely to develop
sooner than a year or two 18 months
during this period whatever we can do in
the way of prevention is necessary but
the second and third-order consequences
of this on our social fabric on our
economic transactions and others we need
requires thinking to the impact on
poverty which all of us in us by
necessity that such a leading role in
this is likely to be negative so how do
we think through in ways to be able to
protect the most poor in the most
vulnerable because of that we welcome
very much your task force and ways of
collaboration and return to this issue
of being able to deal the third order
issue is while all these measures
we presented them to temple of waters
this the disruptive impact objects what
are ways to be able to generate economic
transactions in activities in here again
there is info considerable thinking we
would like to support the meetings that
we do conference in the ministerial
level would like to thank the secretary
for their vital role but the most
important issue is that book pandemics
in particularly climate change are upon
us and without Sark coordinating as such
our vulnerability will increase once
again mr. prime minister that we take
thank you for convening this meeting and
for the follow-up actions and we would
always be ready in winning to
collaborate in to welcome coordination
learn from the best practice in
contribute to it as this global crisis
unfolds
Thank you Thank You excellency I request
his Excellency President solely to make
history month Thank You Prime Minister
first of all I welcome Prime Minister
Modi's proposal especially unprepared
preparation and longer-term economic
recovery
into home emergency co 8 19 emergency
fund as I mentioned in my opening
remarks we believe that a common
approach should address the following
challenges asked to ensure refute
response and share enough experience a
net worth expertise we should create
space for closer cooperation between the
health emergency agencies to ensure that
the country is in shock
unhindered exchanges of information
about the virus and best practices the
Modi's has already received technical
and material support from India as I
have highlighted earlier I would also
like to thank the government of India
for integrating nine Maldivians
from Wuhan it is time that bilateral
cooperation of debt nature be expanded
to regional level where every country
would benefit there is a profound need
to formulate an economic relief package
targeted to the affected countries in
the case of the Maldives such a package
would include budget support to fill the
significant shortfall in revenue gap
that I mentioned earlier third it is
always good to plan ahead to ensure a
quick and sustainable recovery after the
pandemic so we believe that we should
start discussing the long-term recovery
plan for the region for the Maldives
such a plane means initiate in a quick
recovery in the tourism in the region
it also means scaled in a private
investment in tourist resorts and
infrastructure the proposed was growth
in tourist arrivals which in the Modi's
means economic growth thank you
Thank You private servant once again for
convening this meeting Thank You
excellency I now request his Excellency
President Rajapaksa to share his
thoughts
thank you very much
excellency and at the end I want to
thank honorable Prime Minister of India
for convening this important video
conference today and we learned a lot of
lessons from all the participants and I
thank all the heads of state for sharing
their experiences and also good
practices and also I want to thank your
excellency for the series of assistance
that you have proposed especially in the
racing fun go in front and also we all
know there's a shortage of testing kits
another epic treatment not only within
this region or all over the world so
thank you for offering these assistance
to the other regional countries and also
it is very important for us to work
together not totally combating co19
virus but also be prepared for similar
situations in future we have to
understand that it's very important that
the social awareness is very important
in these type of situations now
sometimes the people literally sometimes
we have to take steps that most of some
time to God the people can misunderstand
instead therefore I think it is very
important to all the time that you came
the citizen of the states that we have
to pay further prevent this type of
situation the same time it is important
to control humans and also that we need
to pay it is important to control our
borders that is the major that we have
to take it's a difficult one but we have
to take that those measures to control
effectively control the situation and
also it is very important to have one
place to disseminate information to the
people and also to decide on steps that
we take otherwise it will lead to
confusion among the citizens again I
want to thank President Prime Minister
of India for taking this action and we
hope that we can work together in future
to counter in your situation
thank you very much I call upon her
Excellency Sheikh Hasina
to share her power thank you very much
mr. and well thanks again for Carboni
this meeting this initiative should not
end here it should continue through our
officials also our health experts they
can work together and they can continue
the discussion how we can combat a
present situation or the challenge of
copied 19 and other diseases let us not
forget how we all interconnected in
today's world
now whole world is suffering and you
hold to the people I think this stuff
for the first time it happened because
of this common idea now people from no
everywhere actually a whole world become
very much worried about it
so the initiative with it asked the
South Asian country it is excellent idea
and we should find out a strategy and I
really appreciate and we welcome your
ideas and initiatives I again I
mentioned that this third official can
work and they can activate all these
ideas and also our experts can join
together because I feel that we need to
work together jointly in close
collaboration for addressing these
challenges I feel that our joint effort
we can save our people and also we can
make progress in this alien so I I feel
that your proposals we can our experts
can sit together and we can know examine
that how we can implement it and we can
make progress so I again I thank you
well pass for this initiative and I hope
that together we'll be able to combat
this distress situation I look forward
to being in touch with you all
excellencies as required and hopefully
together we can ensure the safety
security of our people in this region
and again I thank you very much and our
new South secretary-general can
coordinate the follow-up actions which I
feel that that will be you know an
excellent job
Bangladesh would be happy to join all
this Air Force so again Prime Minister
Modi ji I thank you very much for your
initiative that this holding this video
conferences and again I request all our
officials to continue this dialogue
which is very very important at this
moment for our people they preserve
South Asia thank you very much thank you
Thank You excellency I now request his
Excellency Prime Minister only to make
his remarks
Thank You excellency not an apology the
Prime Minister of India our Regent is it
Huayra stop going 90 the epidemic knows
no boundary no nationality and no region
therefore we need to devise ways to
combat this pandemic collectively it is
a common challenge and it demands common
efforts first thing is awareness and
progressive community based
organizations and medical and
non-medical volunteers could be
mobilized in raising awareness and
supporting government agencies we have a
we have to open to our people to avoid
non-essential foreign travels and to
avoid attending mass gatherings and
other large-scale events of our region
is recent traditional medicine we have
to encourage our people to use this as
it for the prevention and treatment of
this disease our way of reading people
know it namaste rather than second hands
can avoid potential threat of foreign to
men transmission of this virus I believe
that our region words of Buddha struck
of emergency medical supplies well
trained medical professionals and
laboratory facilities they should be
deployed at the core of any member state
of CERN in origin paid the hospital's in
the bordering areas could also be
utilized for the screening as well as
treating infected persons in coming
across the border we made great
hospitals medical centers recess
institutions and health orgasm in the
region to build a good network for
sharing experiences research findings
and best practices and critical areas
associated with the prevention and
treatment of this deadly disease when
need to ensure is what supply of
essential medicine equipment and
sanitary materials at the region we may
think of developing a sark level
mechanism to deal with critical health
issues such as this establishment of a
Sark
emergency medical center supported by a
strong funding mechanism would be
desirable in this regard I welcome your
excellency body's proposal and Indians
contribution never will also join so in
this model the economic cost of this
pandemic is eight to be assessed sure it
is going to cost all of us clearly if it
is prolonged regional discussion on
reviving our economies and supporting
each other through providing easy access
establishing value sense and promoting
inter-regional trade investment tourism
connectivity would be critically
important Thank You Prime Minister say
Thank You excellency now I call upon his
Excellency Prime Minister dr. lo -
sharing to share his thoughts thank you
thank you once again I personally feel
that this is a wonderful opportunity for
all of us to share a personal opinion
and I also would like to take this
opportunity actually to thank all the
healthcare providers who are in the
forefront fighting this a war with
unseen enemy and I also would like to
send our prayers and condolences for all
the dear thousands of life's lost I
would like to thank Prime Minister
Modi's initiative in in getting all of
us together as well as proposing to have
emergency COBIT knighting relief fund
that would again be a wonderful
initiative and Bhutan would be a very
active participant to this initiative
thank you very much
I think as we fight this unknown disease
in the acute phase we must also be able
to go through this and see the long-term
consequences of this beat on health or
on long health initiatives maybe as we
fight this disease maybe we will be able
to overcome the acute problem but what
happens to the long-term consequences
what if we all develop the endemic to
this disease what would be international
health requisitions on this so if we can
think through all this then we will
definitely have lesser problems in the
near future to come and also I think we
must of all the of all the initiatives I
would like to repeat and insist that we
must be willing to share share the
limited resources that we have and
through this limited resources we should
now be training more of our health
professionals at a center of excellence
in our region so with this again as we
unfold I would like to propose that we
meet again and as Prime Minister Modi ji
proposed that we also have a relief fund
and like my Adam my other friend said I
think we should have a common consensus
today that left our health ministers
have a forum on this and then through
the SAC Secretariat they must come up
with the SOP on this proposal so with
this I thank all the leaders here and I
thank Prime Minister Modi ji for taking
all this trouble to convene and give us
the opportunity to share our feelings
thank you very much thank you
Thank You excellency now I call upon his
Excellency dr. Zafar Mishra Mirza to
share his thoughts thank you your
excellency Prime Minister Modi and thank
you for your suggestions I think it has
been a constructive and insightful
discussion that we had today and I hope
that we can keep up the momentum and I
think that it is important that in saud
countries we give public health a chance
to bring us together let me as a public
health person myself say that in health
image in the context of health
emergencies we need to take a proactive
approach we should not wait for
emergencies to happen and outbreaks to
take place and then to start our
preparations often all over all of our
health systems are undergoing reform in
our countries but what we forget in this
reform process is that we also have to
invest in invest in health emergencies
preparation response and recovery so the
if we need to take a proactive approach
there and that's what we are now doing
in Pakistan I would also like to mention
that the SARC region generally remains
at least integrated region in the world
I am stating the obvious
the last sock summit was held in Nepal
in 2014 and
our health surveillance system eken isms
are fragmented and necessary regional
cooperation and coordination mechanisms
are largely conspicuous by there are
things we believe that Sark Secretariat
does provide us that platform which can
bring us together and we believe that we
need to use this platform as a platform
for pulling for pooling of resources of
all kinds including technical expertise
national experiences and even financing
which can be used by all the members of
the Sauk region your excellencies I
would also like to mention that we hope
that during this covent emergency of our
member countries will provide and
provide access to emergency assistance
to the all all our regions in our
countries because equity in health is a
fundamental principle of public health
in this regard let me say that it is a
matter of concern that cobalt 19 has
been reported from Indian occupied Jammu
and Kashmir
and in view of the health emergency it
is imperative that four also address the
point that his Excellency President
Ghani made and we understand his concern
about the border crossings and their
closure I want to reassure him that we
have done this for temporary temporarily
so that we can reinforce our point of
entries and land crossings and this is
exactly in the light of the WTO
guidelines and the steps being
implemented by regional states to
contain the spread of the virus this is
a temporary Miette I assure you Pakistan
remains cognizant of the fan astons
needs and requirements and I assure you
that the essential supplies including
food and medicine will be allowed
through as the requisite surveillance
and screening mechanisms are put in
place I thank you very much excellencies
thank you once again for your time and
your ideas we have had a very productive
and constructive discussion today we all
agree that evolving a common strategy
it's critical to handling such
challenges and we agreed to find
cooperative solutions we will share
knowledge based practices capacities and
where possible resources some partners
have made specific requests including
about medicine and equipment my team has
taken careful note of this let me assure
you that we will do our best for our
neighbors latest
ask our officials to maintain close
contact and develop a common strategy in
the spirit of partnership and working
together let us identify nodal experts
from each of our countries and they can
have a similar videoconference one week
from now to follow up on our discussions
today
excellencies we have to fight this
battle together and be how to be knit
together our neighborhood collaboration
should be a model for the world let me
conclude by wishing all our citizens
good health and success in our United
have first to tackle this pandemic in
every region thank you thank you very
much
and never say leaders video conference
on combating COBIT 19 pandemic I would
like to thank all our distinguished
guests for joining us this evening
thank you and Namaskar
you